desde principios de mayo en el tribunal
de parís la justicia francesa examina
las solicitudes de extradición de ocho
italianos ex miembros de grupos armados
de extrema izquierda que golpearon en
italia durante los años 70 y 80 años de
furor ideológico conocidos como los años
de plomo en italia
entre ellos marina petrella de 66 años
se ultimen condenada a cadena perpetua
en italia por terrorismo más de 30 años
después de haber huido de italia le
cuesta encontrar palabras
después del dolor estoy aterrada es un
proceso
no estoy en condiciones de atender una
entrevista
en italia la hipótesis de su extradición
ha suscitado emoción porque aquí estos
fugitivos fueron condenados por crímenes
de sangre como el asesinato de andréa
campagna policía italiano fue abatido en
1970 en milán por césare battisti
miembro del grupo proletarios armados
por el comunismo mi hermano salió por
aquí luego caminó hasta su vehículo que
se encontraba justo aquí cuando se
aprestaba a abrirlo
battisti se puso de pie y le disparó
cinco tiros por la espalda
battisti huyó a francia luego américa
latina' antes de ser detenido en 2019 y
extraditado a italia donde finalmente
admitió su culpabilidad 40 años más
tarde uno de sus cómplices hace parte de
los ocho detenidos a finales de abril en
francia
para el hermano de andrea campaña su
regreso a italia es indispensable para
que se haga justicia
estas personas deben purgar las penas
que les fueron impuestas fueron juzgadas
por tribunales italianos como familias
de víctimas solo queremos que se haga
justicia los que no han purgado un solo
día en prisión es justo que lo hagan y
que lo hagan aquí en italia
este abogado cercano a los medios de
exmilitantes de los años de plomo
considera por el contrario que los
crímenes reprochados son el fruto de un
contexto histórico que pertenece al
pasado se trata de hechos históricos
relacionados con un contexto preciso en
el mundo de aquella época no sólo en
italia un contexto totalmente
sobrepasado hoy en día de tener 42 años
después de los hechos a personas que
abandonaron italia hace tanto tiempo y
que no volvieron a violar la ley desde
aquella época ello parece más bien una
venganza
[Música]
cada año una ceremonia conmemorativa
tiene lugar en el cuartel del comisario
luigi calabresi abatido en 1972 por un
comando de extrema izquierda uno de los
culpables logró huir a francia
[Música]
para mario su hijo el regreso a italia
de estos fugitivos condenados no es una
cuestión de venganza de tanto tiempo
tras todo el tiempo transcurrido no nos
interesa que personas enfermas y mayores
vayan a prisión si lo que queremos es
conocer la verdad que aún falta debería
ser posible intercambiar clemencia por
verdad y otra la clemencia y la adelita
durante 15 años cerca de 15 mil
atentados fueron perpetrados en italia
durante los años de plomo
maurizio piccirilli era fotógrafo de
prensa en aquella época en estas fotos
desfilan los peores momentos de este
periodo
hoy en día considera esencial el regreso
a italia de los fugitivos para que el
país dé la vuelta a la página de estos
años dramáticos
se apodera sin poder garantizar justicia
y por ende hacerles pagar la deuda que
tienen con el estado los ciudadanos y la
sociedad no podemos desembocar en la
pacificación de nuestra sociedad es la
razón por la cual es una página de la
historia italiana que permanece abierta
en suspenso la parte del actor italiana
que ni made in sospecho una página de la
historia italiana en cuyo centro se
encuentran hoy en día estos ocho
fugitivos el examen de sus solicitudes
de extradición podría durar más de un
año